the last of the lord god birds has
vanished into the ether
once the largest american bird of its
kind the ivory-billed woodpecker was
called the lord god bird because
according to legend that's what those
lucky enough to cite the striking
creature would say when they spotted it
inspiring a tribute from
singer-songwriter saffian stevens
it's one of 23 species the u.s is
removing from the protection of its
endangered species act because they are
now extinct there's so many species that
are in dire shape today i think
sometimes it becomes important to
refocus our attention on the ones that
we can save and the ones that need our
attention right now and so so i think
it's it's a it's a sad thing it's a
difficult thing
conservationists say extinctions are
accelerating due to climate change and
habitat loss like the forest clearing
that largely wiped the ivory-billed
woodpeckers sheltering trees from a
southwestern landscape that stretched
from the swamps of louisiana to the
florida everglades hawaii was home to
the most species on the list including
eight woodland birds and one plant many
of these species particularly those in
the pacific islands were rare or very
uncommon at the time that they were
found and when they were listed
unfortunately that means that they were
not able to
benefit from the provisions of the
endangered species act before going
extinct
the endangered species act has saved the
gray wolf along with american icons like
bald eagle and the american alligator
but making the endangered list takes
years a dozen on average leaving 47
species to vanish so far while in
regulatory limbo
others like the disappearing monarch
butterfly still wait as the planet warms
and their habitats dwindle along with
their chances for survival john hendren
al jazeera